former Vice President Joe Biden in
California senator Kamla Harris were
back together for the first time since
they were sparring at the democratic
debate the presidential hopefuls are now
both saying they oppose federally
mandated busing at an education forum in
Houston Friday the two described the
qualifications they are looking to see
in an education secretary I promise you
that the person who is nominated will be
someone who comes from public schools in
an interview Friday Biden admitted
Harris's pointed attack caught him off
guard since she knew his late son beau
he also said he would welcome the
possibility of having a female running
mate but did not mention Harris by names
CBS News political reporter Caitlin Hugh
burns joins us now this morning Caitlin
let's start there that interview that
Biden had on Friday beyond just talking
about Kamala Harris he also turned his
attention to the president President
Trump called him a bully talked about if
the president was re-elected it would be
the end of NATO is this a smart turn for
him as the campaign really is just
getting going at this our vice president
has always focused his campaign on being
the best person to take on Donald Trump
so he's very much been waging a general
election campaign from the very
beginning but what's he's starting to
figure out or realize is that he has to
get through the primary first and all of
his opponents are seeking or sensing
weaknesses in him and they saw some of
that in the debate and we're also seen
that in polls and from voters that we've
been talking to on the ground for the
past several weeks and month they'd like
Joe Biden they appreciate that he's in
this race but there is a soft support
for him which means these voters are
looking and interested in other
candidates as well but this was
interesting because if the debate you
watch it and you think there's this big
divide between Joe Biden and Kamala
Harris but then they just say yesterday
they're opposed to federally mandated
busing right so this is going to be
something that is going that Kamala
Harris is going to have to come up with
an answer to she's kind of been talking
about this and used the debate as really
a moment for her to break through but
now it's the follow-up on policy and I
think these two really reflect different
angles within the democratic
party right now you have Joe Biden who
is running the more traditional campaign
and Kamala Harris representing the more
the the kind of newer wing of the party
or where the party thinks that they
might be okay we want to go back to the
US Census you now hearing the president
say this is about congressional
districting and that they need this for
political reasons people were watching
this all week and they saw that the the
Supreme Court said you can't do this now
here we are again where does it stand
and is it about congressional
redistricting that's right well
originally the Supreme Court dismissed
this saying that it was contrived the
administration originally used the
Voting Rights Act to support their
theory of the case and they said that
that was contrived kicking it back to
the White House and kind of opening it
up for them to come back with something
else now the question is can they make a
compelling argument you heard the
president talking about redistricting
which is a political issue but this is
why the census is so important because
it has to do with representation in
Congress how billions of dollars in
federal funds are allocated and right
now the census helps us determine how
how these districts are drawn based on
overall population not on who is a
citizen and that's what opponents of the
president's actions here are really
concerned about under representing
everybody here so but this deadline
passed yesterday now right and the
president has been asking them to hold
off and to pause I think the bottom line
here is that the president wants to be
appearing to show that he is going to
fight this to the end because this is
something that could very much advantage
him especially if he's realized saying
even there could be an ad on he could
add something later like like a staple
on top of butter census there don't mind
that hey Caitlin thank you very much